es ciudad de dios pero no es en brasil
es un asentamiento de guayaquil ecuador
fue poblado por evangélicos protestantes
allí viven 40.000 personas sin servicios
básicos en viviendas precarias hacinados
y rodeados de violencia la onu llama a
esto una trampa de pobreza de la que
difícilmente se puede escapar es de allí
hay otros temas asociadas en temas de
salud bien hay una alta productores en
enfermedades el tema educativo también
es grave en ciudad de dios pertenece a
monte sinaí en las montañas de la ciudad
donde viven 500.000 personas
hay 55 asentamientos irregulares pero
también organizaciones criminales en
este 2022 ha habido 861 homicidios es el
32 por ciento del total del país una
gran inseguridad
imaginen por bañarme hasta me pueden
atar violar ya yo antes vivía en un
bañito
era un bañito de plástico que cualquiera
metía la mano desgarraban el plástico
que no me hacía
guayaquil es el principal puerto al
pacífico de ecuador lo que la convierte
en un centro mundial de distribución de
cocaína bandas de narcos tienen
presencias en las calles en las
prisiones y en las montañas por lo que
tras una bomba el pasado domingo el
gobierno decretó el estado de excepción
ante la crisis de seguridad interna